so we're going to do a game today
against -10 and it seems that I am the
real - Carlsen of the real - cousin the
Royal Magnus Carlsen don't know why I'm
playing - 10 yes yeah for those who are
stuck at minus 10 you got to get
yourself together so I'm finding bitter
gambit opening today don't know why but
let's see how it goes c5 that looks
excessively risky to me now I'm going to
change this night away his own structure
is a little bit broken now I'm gonna
hand go hunting for points or am I going
to develop one piece first 97 that looks
ridiculous g6 let's go
h5
that's that looks like something Magnus
h5 would do
ahaha Queen b6 now I was intending
Knight g5 but that probably doesn't work
yeah whatever
let's go for it anywhere lone castles
hmm position is probably pretty bad now
okay going to try and trick you it's
going a six now I will sacrifice the
night
you didn't take the night why not I
don't get this who is this - 10 and why
are you people losing time I don't get
this one bit Bishop h6 now I will what
will I do now I don't know maybe but my
position is still lost could be could be
so I'm trying to figure out the way to
get out let's start with a check I kind
of bit too bad he has to block it with
the night now I need to bring the other
work into the game somehow but I cannot
release seeds
almost saw a brilliant way well didn't
work okay so we need to get back into
swindle mode how do we swindle - time
okay Queenie five let's try that Queen a
five maybe I'll have a discovered check
next rook Yeats minus ten is keeping his
calm and barring any major hiccups
system in this game no I'm just kidding
not really
let's try basics just reducing is the
airspace for this king little bit
further now I'm getting mated what's
that all about
if I go King f1 I actually not getting
ready but I have to exchange Queens I
was a bummer
route g6 - time is completely winning
let's see if you'll manage to finish the
game off in style try and bring the
brook back around just change this away
the night
- ten is not displaying perfect
technique he has so many extra pieces
that it's more than enough trying to
attack the form III I'm losing even more
material it's time to resign
okay so that was a bummer let's try a
new one this time I'm going to take it
even more seriously see what open you
place it's going from Sicilian
I don't want to play the open Sicilian
because Magnus time is a tactical beasts
I think this line is what I play
nowadays but minus ten he's too young he
doesn't know this she does not know this
at all it takes
what's that all about okay I retreat now
I'm asking him how are you going to Wow
are you for real just offering me the
Hornet 7 g7 I mean okay you guess it
back we I should play g3 instead and now
castles and once again minus 10 has a
fine position 'if I've some sense it's
Bishop c5 nests b6 this one I however I
don't like will I be able to refute it
see you next week
Bishop c4 I change plans now I want to
put the bishop in the middle Knight
comes out to sea for we should be for
him
such a tricky guy
hmm I gotta say I don't like playing -
time she is too strong
let's try and win some material ok so
I'm probably winning an exchange or do I
just want a positional advantage
I want the position of advantage chasing
is Bishop away now once again now we'll
have a beautiful square for the knight
on d5 where it cannot be attacked by a
narrow base pieces now I'm starting the
Queen side attack creating a past palm
and from then on it should be a matter
of technique now Beatrice takes this I
don't get I like this kind of game much
more now we're playing without any
tactical tricks and then - time is
pretty helpless
so just Queen Queen up here just going
to make a couple of waiting moves now
creating a path form and i blundered
[ __ ] you can undo maybe I didn't blunder
placate is asking me to undo my last
move but I shall not actually it looks
like I'm still winning that's just pure
luck
if I hadn't been talking I just kept
kept my mouth shut
people might have thought this was all
planned it's all a brilliant plan but
unfortunately I already gave away that I
did not have control in this game now
I'm fixing this pawn structure advancing
with a king and now we're soon coming to
the point where my position would be
women
even without the Knights and the phone
now I will bring back the knight into
play can win in several ways now I think
the easiest way is just to to create a
past form his King is in prison I know
what did what he did now I could sell
met him that would be fun but I'm not
going to is going to self-destruct the
King sees that his forces are gone so
he's committing suicide now I'm going
just going to promote to Bishop and
check back with the Knights yippee so
you see that's the way to play against
play - get a positional advantage
I mean - time get a positional advantage
screw it up and then win luckily with
tactics